ciao ragazzi per chi non lo sapesse le
ultime due settimane sono stati
abbastanza intense ho avuto a che fare
con una persona positiva il covip
e questa roba completamente stravolto la
mia esistenza ma allo stesso tempo mi ha
anche aperto gli occhi ecco perché ho
deciso di fare un video dopo un po di
domande che ho ricevuto in di m su
instagram riguardo a questa cosa durante
tutto quanto il periodo che ho condiviso
all'interno delle stories visto che ora
breve che cosa è successo ma se c'è un
insegnamento che ho tratto da tutto
questo è che bisogna sempre fare
attenzione non esistono diagnosi visive
non esistono diagnosi morali non
esistono diagnosi etica e quindi un tuo
amico non vuol dire che siccome un tuo
amico automaticamente sarà negativo così
come non è detto che uno sconosciuto
debba essere per forza positivo non è
una cosa che passano solamente le
persone è una cosa che possano passare i
materiali banalmente se non sta attento
e allo stesso tempo e non ci sono ancora
degli studi che riescono a far capire
effettivamente quanto gli animali
possano essere pericolosi tra virgolette
e per animali intanto il pelo degli
animali come veicolo ho letto sul sito
del ministero della salute che dicevano
per ora devono fare saper qua sotto che
intero degli animali viene trattato come
una superficie qualsiasi e quindi il
virus può resistere al massimo 72 ore
sopra il pelo quindi facciamo attenzione
questo non vuol dire che gli animali
possono avere il covip ci sono dei casi
sporadici non ci sono ancora ricerche
ben chiare ma li sto trattando come se
fossero diciamo dei comodini che si
muovono mistero però velocemente cosa è
successo sabato 4 3 2 1 lo dico subito
sabato 3 ottobre quando ancora non era
passato nessun tipo di decreto sono
stata una festa di compleanno di una mia
carissima amica insieme ad altre persone
uno più ipocondriaco sul co lead
dell'altro vi dico solo che uno degli
amici aveva il termometro quello lì per
misurare la temperatura per farvi capire
il livello ed era tipo la prima volta
che usciva da casa dopo la quarantena
buona stella comunque era una festa in
maschera una cena con delitto tema
scozia quindi io sono stato esposto al
covent sia dal punto di vista delle zone
aeree proprio principali ma sia dal
punto di vista delle zone aerofagia
quindi praticamente senza mutande potevo
avere preso il covip anche nel q scherzi
a parte passa un pochino di tempo il
venerdì della settimana dopo salvo
insieme a mio fratello enrico non
facciamo in tempo ad arrivare che mi
arrivò la chiamata hicks e ypsilon sono
positivi arcade hicks e y erano presenti
alla cena e y ce l'avevo seduta qui ero
a milano per due motivi una raccolta di
beneficenza quanto riguarda la que vous
che davanti simile ha subito e qua sotto
se potete donare a me farebbe piacere e
un intervista importante per prantoni
sansa un sincero c'è stato un momento
nel quale detto porca miseria ma ti pare
che me lo sono preso facciamo queste due
cose non posso farle saltare
mi sono messo un bel tailleur di
responsabilità e ho detto sai che ti
dico
avvisiamo tutti facciamo saltare tutto
quanto ho fatto saltare tutto quanto
perché è importante proteggere gli altri
ora so che qualcuno mi aveva dato
dell'ipocondriaco dell'esagerato magari
ci ha pure ragione magari effettivamente
si sta speculando sul covip solamente un
influenza non è vero niente di quello
che ci dicono io cerco di essere
responsabile quindi non possa fare
quello che mi pare laddove lo stato la
legge il ministero della salute mi
emozionano di fare diversamente è quindi
così ho fatto sono tornato a roma
privatamente e ho fatto il primo test un
gran ciato li soda e mi hanno infilato
il tampone su per il naso e fatto lo
stesso tempo il suo logico quindi
risultava negativo che il serio logico
invece da una presenza minuscola
minuscolo di gm per chi non sapesse di
cosa sto parlando il tampone va a capire
se c'è un no il virus per farla proprio
in soldoni il siero logico fa un'altra
cosa non riesce a controllare il virus
facciamo finta che il virus sia un ladro
quello che ti dice sappi che ci sono
tante e quella banca dieci poliziotti
armati quindi se ci sono dieci
poliziotti armati ossia e quanti corpi
vuol dire che c'è qualcuno dentro che
sta rompendo voglio quindi stranamente
io avevo le mie igm che erano vagamente
presenti ma ero negativo quindi ho un
sistema immunitario totalmente
l'efficiente oppure c'è un qualcosa che
non tornava ho ripetuto il suo logico e
dava sempre quella luminescenza anche se
non l'ho più vista proprio ma io sono
daltonico alzato le mani anche
l'infermiera ho detto vabbè è quello che
mi hanno detto è stato aspetta un po di
tempo poi allora tu dovessi risultare
positivo il tampone risulterà positivo
perché andrà a prelevare il virus e allo
stesso tempo il senologico avrà una
bella lineetta sulle igm ed etoo
anticorpi stanno facendo una lotta
interiore una piccola informazione nel
cielo
oltre alle gm esistono lei gigi che sono
una memoria cosa vuol dire sono i
poliziotti che rimangono davanti alla
banca dopo che il crimine è stato
sventato rimettono le pistole in tasca e
continua in un certo senso ha fare le
sentinelle per un periodo più o meno
breve questo qui il dato che compare
all'interno del suo logico che ti indica
l'hai avuto ma adesso tutto a posto
sono rimasto quindi a casa con quei
poracci di mio fratello enrico che
praticamente girava per casa con il
mitra come se fossi un appestato ha
dormito qui in un materasso gonfiabile
che ogni mattina si sgonfiava e lui si
addormenta su un materasso e si
risvegliava su un tappeto a terra
durante le lotte e graziana quest'altra
nemica che è stata gentilissima allo
scoperto davanti a lei e quindi anche
lei era un pochino infognata ed è stata
il motivo per cui sono riuscito ad
andare da milano a roma privatamente
all'interno della sua macchina che era
diventato una possibile bomba
batteriologica
dopo quindi bel po di giorni ho rifatto
il tampone come consigliato dagli
infermieri che questa è stata molto
molto più difficile lo ammetto ho deciso
di fare il tampone e tramite l'asl
quindi con il drive in
è stato un avventura ho contattato il
mio medico di base gli ho spiegato tutto
quanto mi ha mandato la fattura
elettronica senza bisogno di vederci mi
sono infilato in macchina e sono andato
io questo a roma a fiumicino
l'ho fatto a fiumicino perché perché era
l'unico che ho sapessi aperto 24 ore per
tutta la notte sono partito di casa alle
9 sono arrivato lì alle 10 perché ho
sbagliato strada e ho fatto il mio campo
né alle 5 del mattino una fila infinita
organizzato benissimo toccato veramente
con mano l'impegno la fatica la
dedizione e anche la fluidità con la
quale tutto quanto è successo c'era una
sola postazione aperta che quindi spiega
anche le sette ore di attesa poracci gli
infermi gli infermieri
l'infermiere e i tecnici i laboratori
hanno fatto un lavoro assurdo bravissimi
veramente chapeau a questi qua che si
sono smazzati non voglio sapere quanti
tamponi ho visto persone che si sono
lamentate gente che dicevo ma ci
dovrebbero essere molte più postazioni
anche perché è l'unico posto nel quale
le persone possono farlo di notte quindi
c'era mezza roma fatemi sapere
ovviamente che cosa meno stato riguarda
le postazioni se ne dovrebbe essere
compito di qualcuno insomma io mi sono
ritenuto soddisfatto perché mi aspettavo
di uscire da lì almeno nel 2021
l'infermiere è stato molto premuroso
perché oltre a cercare di prendere un
eventuale presenza di virus anche
cercato di prendere il materiale
organico dal mio cervello con il tampone
quando me l'ha infilato una stella e a
quel punto mi ha chiesto di aspettare
una mezz'oretta nel parcheggio negativo
tutto quanto la mia paura è la mia ansia
di un contagio sono finite no ma devo
dire che questa esperienza mi ha dato
maggiore consapevolezza ecco perché vi
ho chiesto su instagram di farmi sapere
quali fossero delle esperienze personali
che avete avuto delle domande o magari
anche semplicemente delle informazioni
che pensate di uno strano circolando
abbastanza per riguardo a questo virus
quindi prende il mio telefono che ne
leggo subito qualcuna che ho selezionato
e sensibilizzare chi può a scaricarsi
immuni ora per chi non lo sapesse immuni
è una applicazione anche entra in
contatto con tutte quante le gemelle
presenti
negli altri cellulari qualora dovesse
risultare positivo io metterò sulla mia
up immuni solo positivo al co ed è
automaticamente mandare un messaggio a
tutte quante le persone con le quali io
sono entrato in contatto in prossimità
dei pensieri ecco delle perplessità
legate a questa app e magari qualcuno di
voi mi sembra pure rispondere e chiarire
un po le idee
ma se io sto in macchina e nella
macchina affianco a vetri chiusi c'è una
persona che poi risulta positiva
l'app mi dirà che ho avuto un contatto
una persona positiva oppure no cioè
quante notifiche rischio di ricevere che
in realtà non sono notifiche di vero
contatto ma sono anche solo di
prossimità in realtà tutelata non lo so
è sono domande che mi faccio in maniera
istintiva
io nel dubbio comunque ma sono scaricata
al consiglio pura boy sono un'operatrice
al 112 di brescia ragazzi mettetele ste
cazzo di mascherine la mettiamo
io non ho ancora capito come distinguere
i banali sintomi influenzali con quelli
del covip
in realtà ci sono persone presenti alla
famosa festa col kilt che sono state
contagiate da xy
tutti loro hanno perso il gusto ma
esistono un sacco di persone che hanno a
diarrea altri che hanno mal di testa
altri che hanno dolori alle ossa altri
ancora che vanno lo fanno anche con
ciano niente quindi forse dall'alto
della mia ignoranza ti dico un medico è
la persona più giusta da chiamare anche
se devi essere fortunata perché il
motivo per cui in delle persone sono
state contagiate è stato proprio legato
al fatto che mixa aveva chiamato il suo
medico ha detto di avere un raffreddore
questo qui ha detto ma no non è comodo
ma è tranquillo è in realtà era colin
quindi forse l'unica cosa che può darti
una risposta è un tampone tra il tampone
non fatto dal medico dx mi raccomando
ricordi numeri da chiamare in caso di
sintomi invece di andare in pronto
soccorso sono infermiera siamo sommersi
assolutamente sì ragazzi vi lascio qua
sotto un link con tutti quanti i numeri
da chiamare
non ve li metto qui sovraimpressione
perché sono tanti a seconda della vostra
regione e compagnia bella prendete
veramente due secondi per andare
nell'info box e cliccare sul link
il tampone esclusivamente a pagamento
anche in caso di sintomi
no il tampone dell'asl quello lì e che
quindi fai al drive in
non è mai a pagamento
mette in coda e automaticamente te lo
fanno se hai la ricetta del medico
importantissimo mentre invece quello a
pagamento non richiede alcun tipo di
ricetta puoi farlo oa casa o nelle
strutture abilitate
egli però l'unica cosa che richiedono
air cash sono positivo da una settimana
vorrei sapere da quando devo contare i
dieci giorni di isolamento
no non funziona così ad oggi i dieci
giorni di isolamento sono previsti solo
nel caso in cui tu sei stato a contatto
con un positivo ma ancora non si sa se
se positivo oppure no è solo dieci
giorni solamente se alla fine dieci
giorni fa il tampone e quel campo ne
risulta negativo tuchia ma comunque il
tuo medico e informati perché io non so
quando vedrai questo video e soprattutto
se ci saranno state dell'evoluzioni però
ad oggi tu devi rimanere a casa chiamare
il tuo medico e aspettando e guarire
l'unico caso ad oggi è che si rimanga
positivi anche dopo e 21 giorni e dopo
21 giorni se si è positivi e non si
hanno sintomi allora si può tornare alla
vita normale ad oggi informatevi ragazzi
perché continuano a cambiare
costantemente queste informazioni e le
potete trovare facilmente su internet
sui siti ufficiali del ministero della
salute la ricostruiscono verso messaggio
poi parlare delle mascherine in tessuto
che non proteggono ma sono solo belle da
usare e usare quelle è come non portarle
grazie certo e parliamo ai ragazzi ci fa
riprendere le mascherine in farmacia
sicuramente quelle di tessuto sono molto
stilose quello che vi consiglio io se
volete essere stilosi la mettete doppia
perché il terrore per il covip
l'influenza sicura lo dicevo prima
magari tutto contro uno spara occhio
magari tutto quanto una manipolazione
dei media che per qualche motivo stanno
cercando di creare un terrore in tutto
quello che viene detto ci sono anche dei
professionisti lo ribadisco che
affermano che effettivamente è solamente
uno sparaco e cover e se mi viene detto
l'influenza uccide di più del covip io
non penso a ok il copy di non è niente
penso a cavolo allora forse sei dovuto
essere un minimo più accorto anche nei
confronti di influenza o delle persone
anziane più fragili e cagionevoli nella
mia vita alle quali tengo e per egoismo
personale perché io c'è una salute di
ferro in chiaro detto migratori quelle
persone io sono disposto a prendere
altrimenti egoismo puro ragazzi perché
pensare che mia nonna lo stesso precisa
dal copit e sentirmi dire eh ma tanto
anche l'influenza per ucciderla mi
farebbe solo rosicare magari hai ragione
tu è una semplice influenza e sicura tra
quale prezzo info generale lo si diventa
immuni al comite si può riprendere per
chi ignora assolutamente vero cioè
tendenzialmente ci dovrebbe essere un
periodo nel quale i gg le famose sono
attive e quindi un pochino fanno da
scudo
inoltre hanno loro potrebbe tornare uno
potrebbe continuare a prendere il copy
dall'infinito serve per forza
prescrizione medica per fare il tampone
sì per fare quello dell'asl 9 fare
quello privato di quanto vi sentite più
furbi quando mettete la mascherina solo
sulla bocca non sul naso ragazze è
fondamentale la mascherina messa così
non così c'è a volte ci sarà pensate che
proteggono la loro barba che tu dici ok
barbaresco tutto il resto
fateci attenzione ho perso il lavoro per
il covip e con una famiglia a carico
non so cosa fare sono messaggi come
questi che mi spingono a cercare di
essere più responsabile a non giocare
con le regole non cercare di raggirarle
in qualche modo per un mio tornaconto
personale per poter stare più sereno io
cerchiamo di giocare il nostro ragazzi
le nostre azioni possono veramente
influire sulla vita di altre persone che
ci crede un nobile che sono vere sono le
conseguenze che poi persone così devono
affrontare si parla di morti ma un'altra
cosa che veramente drammatica a vedere
quante vite stanno venendo fermate per
il comit e lo sto parlando di vite che
si spezzano all'interno di un reparto di
rianimazione non sto parlando di persone
che perdono la vita sopra le persone che
davanti a questa pandemia più di altri
si sono ritrovati completamente
sottosopra che hanno veramente bisogno
di una forma d'intervento ainsi va per
poter mandare
avanti la loro quotidianità e
sopravvivere in questo mondo spero che
questa situazione si possa risolvere il
nostro governo pensi a dei modi per
darvi una mano per quanto riguarda alle
vostre famiglie i vostri figli e le
vostre realtà che sono state
completamente bloccate spero che questa
seconda ondata possa venire presto
renderci più forti più uniti più
responsabili cerchiamo di aprire un
dibattito costruttivo su questo
argomento siamo qui per informarci per
condividere le nostre esperienze magari
sentirci meno soli un bacio ciao